>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> ERIC FRAZIER:
Welcome everyone.
Welcome to the rare book and
special collections division,
Thursday at 3 lecture series.
My name is Eric Frazier, I'm a
rare book reference librarian
in the rare book special
collections division
and I'm thrilled to introduce
Adrenne Lundgren to talk to us
about photographic
technology manuals.
Those manuals that are here
in the rare book division.
Adrenne is conservation
division's photographic liaison
for rare books.
She's also been instrumental
in helping us understand
the intellectual
and cultural value
of these pieces.
Adrenne has spent quite a bit
of time developing an index
to those books that have
early photograph and examples
of photographic paper.
She's a wonderful
colleague and her excitement
for the material is contagious.
Even after she's left the room,
you're wondering why you
haven't spent more time
with 19th century
photographic [inaudible].
Yeah, I know, right.
So, I halfheartedly thanked her
1 time when she brought a manual
down to us and she put it
in front of me and said,
look at this piece, it's made
with uranium and I didn't want
to seem like a beginner
[inaudible].
So, I just, you know, very
casually threw up an objection
as to are you sure that's safe?
And she said oh yeah,
I checked it
out with our [inaudible]
counter.
You know, we're very impressed
when we get a new loop,
you know, a new magnifying loop,
but apparently the [inaudible]
counter is down stairs.
She was able to spend quite a
bit of time with this collection
and other photographic
collections
when she was the
[inaudible] in 2012.
Her project was called
photographs of Holland,
excuse me, photographs
of [inaudible],
creating a material spaced
catalog resume for photography
and she has a web cast by the
same name that's available
on the Library of
Congress web cast page.
Adrenne's talk will
last about 35 minutes
and if we can keep the
questions to the very end,
that would be very,
that would be helpful.
And for those of you
in the audience today,
you can see that we have quite
a few examples around the table.
At the very end,
if we let Adrenne
and Adrenne alone turn the
pages for those pieces,
that would be helpful as well.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Adrenne Lundgren.
[ Background noise ]
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Wow.
This is a big crowd, like way
bigger than I ever thought.
When you take photo
manual perfectly.
This crowd.
All right.
So, we're in the [inaudible]
room of the Library of Congress
and I just feel so
honored to speak today
about photographic
technical manuals in this room
because a lot of
people would argue
that maybe they don't
have a place here and with
such prestigious company,
but I hope that after today,
you'll maybe think that
they do have a little place
that they could hold in here
and that they're really
incredible artifacts
that can tell us a
lot about image making
and photography of
the 19th century.
So, the TR classification
of the Library
of Congress is the designation
for photographic technology
and when you're a photo
conservator like me,
this is like the holy grail.
It's like, you wonder something
and you go into the TR section
and the answers are
like there for you.
So, when I came to the
Library of Congress,
I went into the TR
section having been
in other institutions where
that section's very small,
maybe a couple hundred books
and we had 78,000 books.
So, I'm like whoa, it's like
[inaudible] that I can see
for row after row after row.
And of course, you know, we're
at the Library of Congress
so you imagine that there are
books that exist nowhere else
in the world and that's true.
But, actually what was
really fascinating to me
about the collection was there
were books with original samples
in them and I became
really interested in these
and really started to see
the untouched potential
in these books.
So, let's get, let's get going.
So, to understand the history
of photography, we really need
to understand that it's
a manufactured history
for the most part which means,
you would buy these things
to make photographs on, right.
So, even as Daguerre was
announcing the Daguerre type
in 1839, he was simultaneously
forming a partnership
with his brother in
law Alfon [inaudible]
and he was marketing
photographic cameras
but also supplies
to make photographs
and photographic varnishes.
So, here's a Daguerre camera.
You can see his label and
he would sign each camera.
They're very cool.
They have one at the
George Eastman museum.
And soon after Daguerre type
plates were manufactured
in factories in the
United States and abroad
and then larger factories
started
to open not only
manufacturing plates,
but also supplying everything
for the process including the
housing the photographs would go
in after they were made.
And so, here's one
of those factories.
This is the E. Anthony and
company later to be E&HT Anthony
and we'll hear about
them later in the talk,
but in this illustration, you
see workers creating brass mats
and preservers like
those you see used
to house this Daguerre
type in the corner.
So, they would make these metal
pieces that then you would put
on to the Daguerre type.
And so, as a conservator,
I wonder like,
wouldn't it be great to know
which mats E&HT Anthony
were actually making
and like wouldn't it be great
to know if this by E&HT Anthony
or if this artist used
their work or, you know,
if 90% of what we have in
extant Daguerre types is made
by this factory.
Like, I find myself asking
those questions and so far
with the manuals that we
have documented so far,
we can't necessarily answer
that particular question,
but these manuals do tell
us a tremendous amount
about the manufacturers of
photographic papers, varnishes,
accessories, paper
mats and mounts.
So, much of that information
about this manufactured
history is stored
in these 78,000 volumes that
we have here at the library.
And information like this
gives us an unpreceded look
at like the industry surrounding
photography that was used
to make billions of
images in the 19th century.
[ Background noise ]
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: So,
we should understand
this history much better.
So, here's one such
[inaudible] that we found
in a photographic serial called
the Philadelphia Photographer.
And so, besides just
providing a sample photograph,
these images are often
accompanied by recipes
and then the advertisements.
So, the recipe will tell you
exactly how this photograph was
made and then the advertisement
will tell you what company
marketed it, how they
marketed it to photographers
which tells you a lot about
like the overall like goals
or what aesthetics
they are appealing
to for photographers
and artists.
And we also will know when
the sample was produced
because they're made in books
and books have a
publication date.
So, they have this great dating
stamp on them that's reliable.
And we know that this
print for instance,
is a salted paper
print from the recipe.
It was made on SAX paper.
So, to know the paper
is very unusual.
It was gold toned using alkaline
gold toner in post process
with a gum Arabic varnish.
We also know that this
print had to have been made
between June and July of 1864.
So, to have this level of detail
about a photographic print is
very rare if you find one kind
of in the wild, right, but
we have one captured for us
at the perfect specimen
of 1864 salted paper.
And when we have this level of
detail, this knowing the paper,
how it was made, what its
varnish was and the date,
then we can call this
a reference collection.
And so, it's something
that conservators
and scientists refer to a lot.
A reference collection
is a collection
that provides known quantities
for which unknown quantities
can then be compared
and these collections can be
examined either analytically
or visually and they tell
us a lot about works of art.
All right.
So, just for some of
you who don't know a lot
about conservation and kind of
things to do with conservation,
the use of reference
collections and the aid
of technical art history was
really established in the 1930's
with the creation of the
Forbes pigment collection.
And so, Edward Forbes was the
director of the Fog Art museum
at Harvard and he began to
collect pigments of known date
and chemical composition in
order to really aid people
in understanding
painted materials
and then he assembled this
collection of over 4,000 samples
and then split that
amongst institutions
to really promote collaborative
research and the Library
of Congress was lucky
enough to be a recipient
of Forbes pigment collection
and that's now housed
in the conservation division.
And so, various types of
analysis could be done
on these pigments by
participating institutions
and now that analysis is
stored in an online portal
and then shared
cross-institutionally.
So, you'll see parallels as we
go through between that type
of the Forbes reference
collection and these books
because while we aren't going
to share these books
cross-institutionally,
they're not so rare
that they already
exist cross-institutionally.
And so, if we can
start to catalog them
and share our analysis
and our observations,
we have a disperse
reference collection already.
So, as photography
became more valued.
I'm just going to check my time
because I could just
go on all day.
As it became more valued,
gaps in our knowledge
about the technical
history were revealed
and more demanding
questions were asked
of conservators regarding
image making and technique.
And so, forgeries
such as this scandal
of posthumously printed Lewis
Hine photographs emerged
and conservators were really
on the forefront of responding
to these questions of
when was this print made,
was it really made
by this person.
And one of these conservators
was named Paul [inaudible].
I shouldn't say was,
he's still alive.
[ Background noise ]
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN:
He's now the director
of the lens media lab
at Yale and he began
to build a reference
collection on silver,
20th century silver gelatin
papers and he wanted to be able
to look at that reference
collection and really study it
for the paper making fibers
that were used at the time,
the paper thickness, optical
brightening dyes and all
of this aided in the conclusion
that those Lew Hine prints
that we saw were
actually not printed,
could not have been printed
during his life time.
So, here's these.
Paul gave me these slides.
He grew this reference
collection
in this obsessive eBay buying
spree where he just kind
of lost his mind and
he made this incredible
reference collection.
So, what. So, it's great.
I mean, don't get me wrong,
but as things became earlier,
he couldn't find
them on eBay anymore.
So, what we find with his
collection is that there's not,
there are not any
samples that predate 1900.
But, where does the 19th century
reference collection exist
for photography?
And I would argue that, that
19th century collection exists
in these photographic
technical manuals.
So. So. Okay.
So, then I decided
let's do a pilot project
and really show the potential
of what we can unleash
if we catalogue these samples.
So, with the help of a junior
fellow that I had for 10 weeks,
we looked at, we
catalogued 1,500 samples
from the collection and Paul
[inaudible] built this database
and then the fellow put all
of the samples in and we.
Okay. So, here's your database
and you can see we
capture information all
about the specimen,
not only an image of it
but where it's located
in what book, the date,
any manufacturing info,
if it has a recipe
that accompanies it, if
it has an advertisement
that accompanies it and then
we can pull up images of all
of those relevant information.
From this initial project,
we were able to see
that samples were
valuable in 3 major ways.
They informed us
about rare processes.
So, processes that you
might never see otherwise.
They had a wealth of
information on retouching
and hand coloring materials,
something that is virtually
undocumented elsewhere.
And then collectively,
the information
about known manufactured papers
provided us with a wealth
of knowledge about artists
practice and then larger trends
in marketing and manufacture.
So, those papers provided us
with like a big data approach.
And that's kind of why I call
this talk mapping the genome
of 19th century photography
because just
like they were doing
with the human genome,
the more you add,
the more you know.
And so, it really is
a big data project.
You have to add more
to get more out of it.
And so, this is just
the beginning of that,
but let's take a look
at some of these gifts
that these books have in them.
First, on rare processes.
So, this is one of my favorites.
When I opened this
book and I found this,
I was like oh my
gosh, it's the best.
It's called a nonpareil.
I had read about.
I had never seen one before.
So, it was in our
Spanish translation
of The Silver Sunbeam
by [inaudible]
which sounds really
cool in Spanish
and this image is
similar to a tin type
in its final construction.
So, it's a varnished collodion
image on a coated iron plate.
So, very similar to a tin type
if you're familiar with that,
but the process for making this
image is extremely different
than that of a tin type.
A tin type is a direct positive
image meaning each one is unique
in the world and you don't
use a negative to make it.
That plate was in the camera
and you get one, right.
This image was made using
a negative and thus,
because you had to put
the negative in contact
with the sensitized paper
or the sensitized plate,
you couldn't use wet collodion
or the negative would
just stick to it.
So, you had to use an
alteration called dry collodion
which is kind of
a rare variation.
It. So, what these
actually means in the end is
that these images
could be reproduced.
So, there could be many of these
because they were
made with a negative.
These images are extremely
rare and it was a real treat
to find one of these and I love
how they have the advertisement
too for the plate
and they say it's
like porcelain and it elicits.
I love this.
Like, not a ringing endorsement,
but maybe in the 19th century,
you didn't want to sound
like really boastful,
but they're like, it's elicited
the most general expressions
of approval and admiration.
Okay. I'm sold.
Sign me up.
Our plates are stamped.
Be known, all others
are spurious.
[ Background noise ]
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: So,
lots of drama going on.
Another special find in the
collection were these samples
of uranium prints and this one
is out over here by Ernst Leitz
who was the future founder
of Leica camera company.
These 2 samples show
2 distinctive ways
of making uranium prints,
one using silver nitrate
and then one using
potassium ferricyanide.
This book not as
rare as some others,
is found in other collection.
So, there's one at the
National Gallery of Art.
I've seen one at the George
Eastman Museum Library.
So, you see other copies and by,
by existing in other
collections,
it affords us the
opportunity to look at samples
that have been aged in very
different environments.
So, you imagine these are all
being published on the same date
and the same location and
then they get sent out
and they live their
lives in different places
and one ended up at Getty.
Lucky book.
And then one ended up here
at Library of Congress
and by comparing these,
what we can see is
that these have been naturally
aged for us and it tells us
that probably the top process,
it's not fading related
to environmental conditions,
it's fading because there's
inherent vice with this process
that causes it to fade.
So, there's a lot of
wealth that can be gained
from examining these books.
Another one of the
processes that we had
in these were tin types.
So, like I said before,
if you're not familiar
with the structure
of them, they're made
on an iron plate that's
coated with a varnish
and then they have a collodion
layer and then a varnish on top
of that to protect it.
And we had 7 tin types
found in our books,
mostly in the Silver Sunbeam
and then Eastbrook's
the [inaudible] type
and how to make it.
But, while tin types are not
rare, we see them all the time
in antique shops and, you
know, I find them everywhere
in like thrift stores,
but to know what plate,
what manufacturer
made what plate
that we find a tin type on,
that's really rare knowledge.
They usually weren't
marked and so
to actually have an identified
manufacturer associated
with a tin type plate
is really unusual.
And then of course there
are these associated recipes
that go along with these.
And so, even in a small
set of just 7 plates,
you can start to see patterns.
So, we found 2 plates that had
cracking and then when we looked
at the recipes for the
plates, we could determine
that the only ones with
cracking are also the only ones
that were varnished
with diamond varnish.
So, most likely the cracking
that we're seeing is associated
with the varnish that was used.
So, it's interesting things like
that for the technical history
for conservators that's
really helpful information.
And then like I said.
Oh, and then another
thing that is interesting
about tin types is since
they're unique and not made
from negatives, when you're
publishing a book using tin
types and say you have a,
you have 2 tin types per book
and you're doing a
200-book print run,
that's 400 tin type
you have to make.
You can't make those from
negatives so you're shooting,
you're shooting 400 hand coated
plates in front of sitters.
No one's going to sit
for 400 portraits.
They're going to be like
dead by the end, like.
So, what you find is that
even though these books are
catalogued as being exactly
the same within institutions,
in fact the samples vary.
And so, when we talk about
redundancy in collections
and reduction of collections
because of redundancy,
I think that we need
to actually think
about that a little bit more
and make sure that things
that we're calling redundant
truly are redundant before we
talk about [inaudible]
or things like that.
One of the things that we
found that was really great
and I pulled quite a few samples
over here for to you guys
to look at afterwards are
information on hand coloring.
So, hand coloring of
photographs was popular
from the Daguerre type all
the way down, you know,
into silver gelatin
and, but knowledge
of the materials is
actually really rare.
And so, having these actual
samples allow conservators
to test pigments at various
time periods to understand
when something could
have been made,
what pigments would be present
and also because of the nature
of the book format
when it's closed
and it's pushing
all the oxygen out
and it's not letting
air pollutants get in
and there's no light exposure.
[ Background noise ]
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN:
A lot of time we find
that these pigments
are preserved as best
as they could possibly be.
So, some of them look like
they were made yesterday
which is very rare.
While all these samples shown
are remarkable on their own,
for me the most interesting part
of cataloguing these was
really their collective power
to show us larger trends.
So, we not, fully,
[inaudible] of this data so far
and as we collect more samples,
it will be more statistically
accurate, but one thing
that we can do in
collecting this data is start
to map things and chart things.
So, like just, this is
just a very basic chart
which shows different processes
over time and so we can start
to see changes like when
a process is introduced
and when it leaves,
what it's replaced by,
when it was at its peak
or we can just look
at one process within
the data set.
So, this is the salted
paper process.
There's not many sample, we
know it was a very popular
photographic process,
but it wasn't really
a manufactured
photographic process.
You would hand make salted
paper prints in the early years.
So, that's why we only see
occasional mention of it,
but what this graph does
show is this resurgence
of the salted paper
process in the 1890's
which is virtually
undiscussed in the literature
and that resurgence is actually
on a manufactured paper not
a hand sensitized paper.
So, it, this type of work in
cataloguing examples has kind
of redefined some of
these processes for us
and given us a much better
understanding of the evolution
of them throughout time.
Here again we see just
silver gelatin paper,
the one that Paul [inaudible]
is obsessively collecting,
but can't get our samples
because they're before 1900.
And so, you can see how many
samples we have before 1900
and we're not even
close to have,
to have finished
looking at our books.
We have thousands and thousands
of more samples to catalogue.
So, I'm sure the silver
gelatin paper section will fill
in considerably and, you know,
we have one of the
earliest samples is 1881
for silver gelatin paper.
So, some of these manufacturers
only lasted 1 or 2 years.
And so, their appearance
on the market is only
preserved in these manuals.
And then another thing that
kind of was cool to look
at was comparing historic
terms to contemporary terms.
So, just how many terms in
the literature did they have
for say the collotype
and there was
so many proprietary
variations of this process
and they would call it
like [inaudible] process.
Well, a modern researcher
may not know
that [inaudible]
process is a collotype.
So, this type of information can
provide a new primary resource
from which researchers
can really like delve
into something much more deeply.
And then you can also with data
of course, start to map things.
So, this is a map of where the
sample photographs were taken,
but you could also make maps
on where they were manufactured
or where certain processes were
manufactured and you could do
that over time and see the
development of certain hubs
of photographer like, you
know, how did Rochester become
such a center for photographic
development and manufacturing.
So, let's just take one
process and really look at it
and see what the data tells
us about this one process.
So, I chose albumen
prints and for people
that don't know what those are,
they're a photographic print
process, they're on paper
and then they have
an albumen binder
which albumen is
basically egg white
with a silver image material
and here's a really nice picture
of Walt Whitman from
our collection.
So, we call these
albumen prints,
but albumen is kind
of a general term.
There's so many things that
we would put under that,
but they have very
different properties.
A lot of albumen prints
are mat and some are shiny
and some have different
image tones,
some age very differently
from other ones.
[ Background noise ]
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: There are
some that are died with pink
or green dyes which changes
the look of the final print,
but millions of images
were made on albumen paper
so we should really start
to understand the manufactured
history of this paper.
Some of the most
well-known photographers
in history made albumen
prints like Mathew Brady
or Alexander Gardner
or Gustave Le Gray.
When we looked at these books,
we had more albumen samples
than any other process
in the collection.
So, we had 332 albumen samples.
305 of those samples were on
known papers, identified papers,
and the samples ranged
in a 40-year times span.
We had 37 different types
of papers represented
by 30 different manufactures.
So, it's an incredible
wealth that were,
was previously untapped before.
So, let's just look at this in
the identified papers if we make
that as whole and
we make a pie chart,
we see that certain
manufacturers were making most
of those samples.
So, this is just, you
can see that E&HT Anthony
who were making Daguerre types,
now they've moved to albumen
and they've made this
huge amount of samples
in the collection, but what
I think is actually more
interesting is when you look
at the manufacturers over time
and you start to see that
in the hay day of albumen,
we have a huge number
of manufacturers.
There's a really
diverse market out there
and then we have 2 years
where there are no samples
for some reason and then
basically after those 2 years,
E&HT Anthony has
like taken over.
So, I call it egg wars.
It's a like a dirty
business, right?
They're like [inaudible]
through the market and they just
like corporate takeover and,
you know, I imagine all sort
of drama, but, but anyways.
So, they've taken
over this market now
and then there's just
a few small players
that come in at the end.
And so, I think it tells us
how researchers could start
to use this collective aggregate
of data to kind of see trends
that they may not have even
realized were happening before.
So, more data means
better accuracy.
So, we're trying to
get other institutions
that have these collections to
participate in this project.
So, we would provide them
with our empty database
and they could fill it and
then we would take that data
and collect it and then that
data, we're hoping to put online
through the Library
of Congress site
and then any researcher
could query that data
in any way that they wanted to.
And then just for the last
slide I wanted to kind of sum
up things that I've learned
through doing this project
and things that I'd
like people to walk away
from if they're working
in libraries
that have these collections
is kind of the value.
How a lot of times in libraries
we value individual samples.
So, like the rarity of a book
over a lot of times the kind
of large collections, but
there is this real value
in aggregate data that I think
we need to think about more
and this has a lot to do with
how collections are looking
at redundancy because for me,
redundancy always
[inaudible] more data, right.
So, never mind if you
don't enough space,
it's more data for me so.
But also, redundant
like I showed,
redundant may not be redundant.
And so, I think we need to
pay a lot more attention
to what we mean when
we say that especially
when we're thinking
about [inaudible].
I think it's great
for us as librarians
and conservators imbedded
in collections to think
about new ways that subject
matter experts imbedded
in collections can
create primary resources
to encourage new types of
research in the field and just
to remind people
that digitization doesn't
replace these holdings.
That the value of
these samples is really
in the materiality of them.
And so, you can create
a reference image
and that can be helpful,
but what you really need is
to see this photographs
in real life.
And then also to send
people out, you know,
I'm only interested
in photography,
but there's a whole world out
there of technical manuals
and they're amazing
technical manuals
that describe the history of
fabrics the history of paper,
the history of paint,
all these things.
And so, it would be great if
this kind of provided a model
for looking at all these other
technical manuals and started
to catalogue them for, you
know, other people's fields too
because I think they hold a
lot of untouched potential.
And thank you.
Thanks for coming.
[ Background noise ]
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN:
People up here are people
that really helped with this
project and I especially want
to thank Mark [inaudible]
who, and the staff here
who really saw that even though
these weren't [inaudible],
they were still worth
collecting and putting
in the rare book division
which really means a lot.
And we brought sample.
So, you should definitely
take time
and if there's any questions,
I'm happy to answer questions.
>> Adrenne, great talk.
I was just wondering what other
collections have large numbers
of these volumes,
like are other?
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN:
Other institutions?
Well, you guys do it.
National Gallery, it's
not large compared to us.
So, measly collections,
let me think.
No. The George Eastman museum
of course has an
incredible collection.
New York Public Library is
actually really interested
in this project.
They have a great
collection of these books.
I'm sure the British Library has
them or Bibliotheca National.
I haven't contacted
them about yet, but I,
I'm sure that there's a lot
more than we probably know
and there's some really
rare things out there.
Yeah.
>> We refer to them as
boutique collections.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN:
Boutique collection.
I like that.
That's so PC.
Yes.
>> This is not directly
related to the photography,
but it reminded me of a
seminar in graduate school
when we were searching, we
were dealing with searching
for the acceptances
[inaudible] scientific theories,
history of science and
the professor was adamant
about the value of
retaining old textbooks
where the defined things
regarding Biology [inaudible]
and Einstein [inaudible].
So, just wondering
if anyone could speak
to what the retention policy
the Library of Congress
for old textbooks of a
more general [inaudible]
than photography.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: I have
no information about that.
Does someone else know?
>> I do.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Oh, great.
Yay.
>> The collection
policy statements
for textbooks basically states
that we only collect textbooks
when they are sort of the best
research value in that subject.
We don't collect, you know,
[inaudible] or those sort
of basic school textbooks
that we depend
on [inaudible] department
of education [inaudible]
collections.
So.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Thank you.
Yeah.
>> Can you say something about
these books that have as objects
of a, that have a
publishing history.
Why were they published?
How were they published?
How were they distributed?
Did they, were they
promoting something?
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Well, I
think, I can maybe answer part
of that which is when
you're doing a process,
and I actually pulled an
example out of bromoil.
So, I have one up there
that's a bromoil book
and it just has a half tone of
what a bromoil should look like
and then I have a book in
front of it that actually is
about bromoils and
has bromoils in it.
And when you're doing
photography and you're trying,
you're reading about a process
and you've never done it before
and you maybe have never even
seen it, you need a sample
because you don't know what
you're trying to shoot for
and if you're getting that.
And so, these were instructional
manuals for a lot people
and that piece provided
them a reference
of what they were
trying to achieve, right.
>> But, not all of
these processes endure.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Yeah.
So, I mean, I think some of
them were trying to get momentum
like the [inaudible],
maybe it never took off.
Dry collodion is a
little bit [inaudible]
which is why most
people tend to just stay
with wet collodion I think.
It wasn't maybe as easy
from what I've heard.
So, there may have been
technical difficulties
with how easy a process was
which is why we have a sample,
but we don't see them that much.
In the one with the uranium
prints, it was a means
to show all of, all of the
processes that one could do
to make copies of
architectural drawings.
And so, if you look in that
book, there's 10 samples.
So, it's, it's almost
like a complete look
at what people could do to make
architectural drawing copies.
So.
>> Yeah. I was wondering about
what was the market for this
and how did people
find out about.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Well,
when you look in the ack,
a lot of times there's
announcements in the backs
of one book about other
books on the market.
So, I think that they
were kind of reading.
If you were interested in
photography, you might subscribe
to a serial and then
they would review a book
or they would have
advertisements
or often book lists and
I've used those book lists
to find things in collections
because they are so helpful.
Yeah, I don't think
the market was huge.
I don't know.
I mean, some books more than
others maybe, but I think,
you know, making the tin
type and how to make it
and you're making 2 tin types.
I can't imagine your print will
run with being more than 200.
I mean, just seems crazy
to have to even make that.
So, yeah, I don't know exactly.
Yeah.
[ Background noise ]
>> This gets to the issue
of the manufacturer.
I'm researching a
biographical subject who happens
to have been a woman during the
globetrotting era who traveled
in the far east, did a lot
of her own photography.
So, I'm hearing here that
there are a lot of variables.
How much technical proficiency
would have been required
for somebody who is
traveling the world,
you know, carrying equipment.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: It depends
on what process you're
using honestly.
I mean, some processes are
much easier than others
and some are very sensitive
to like heat and humidity.
So, if you're going somewhere
like India and you're trying
to do the, you know,
paper negative process,
that's a tricky process.
You've got to be
really accomplished,
but if you're trying
to do gelatin dry plate,
that's much easier.
So, it really depends.
Yeah. Yes.
Hi.
>> Great talk.
I have 2 questions.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Sure.
>> First I was, I am
surprised that these are
in the rare book collection,
that's like really great
and are there other
collections in the library
that are holding these
types of materials
and I was also wondering
if you could say more
about the technical analysis
that you're doing
on the reference.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Sure.
So, I should say we've only
transferred the most rare
of these books to rare book.
Most of the 78,000 books, not
all of them contain samples.
I would say the 5 to 10%
maybe contain samples.
Those are in general
collections,
but now we've marked them as
special materials and those now,
before they could be checked
out to someone's desk,
now you actually have
to be in a reading room
to get access to
those materials.
So, I feel like that was a big
accomplishment of this project,
was just to draw
attention to that.
We haven't done a huge amount of
technical analysis with these.
Like, XRF, I think,
actually think
that for the national
gallery, an XRF was run
by your department
on one of these
and that would be [inaudible]
into the kind of data part,
but we've put that into
the database hoping
that this cross-institutional
collaboration will start
to take off and that if
someone runs a sample.
I think you guys
ran an [inaudible]
with the silver gelatin
or silver paper
that was toned with
platinum salts.
So, that we've run that, now
that someone else who has
that sample won't
have to run it,
but they'll know
that information.
That's what I would love to see.
Kind of like the Forbes
collection so we don't have
to like reinvent the
wheel every time.
Yeah. Hi.
>> One of the reason, some of
the reasoning behind taking them
into rare is that
we're interested
in documenting the
[inaudible] period of each
of these processes whether it
be printing with movable type
or whether it be
[inaudible] and we viewed this
as another [inaudible]
in book form.
If they had been in paper
form or loose-leaf form,
they probably would have
gone to another division,
but since they're
documenting the origins
of the photographic book,
it makes perfect sense
that we would take them
in especially the ones
that are contained
original materials.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Yeah and I
really tried to focus on things
that didn't exist widely
in other collections
and also things that
documented kind of the first
of something for them.
Yeah. [inaudible]
in photobooks here.
Yeah. Hi.
>> We talked at one time about
the series and the samples
in the series [inaudible].
I'm just wondering in terms
of serials, how many you found
and also if you found anywhere
there should have been a sample
and it was missing.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN:
Oh sure, yeah.
Which is why I was so concerned
about really limiting access
to these in an environment that
was controlled because a lot
of times, like the
Philadelphia Photographer.
So, about serials, many of the
samples are housed in serials.
I would say 90% of the
samples are housed in something
that came out month and each
month you would get a sample.
So, like the Philadelphia
photographer,
every single month you
would get a sample.
Up until about, which
just a tidbit,
but 1895 I think the
postal rules changed
and they started
charging you a lot more
if you put a sample in there.
So, then you see a real decrease
in the amount of samples
that happened, but yeah, serials
are really the source for a lot
of these and I know there should
be one every month and I'll go
and look and samples
will be missing.
And sometimes they were made
by really famous photographers,
civil war photographers,
important people.
So, I think that's why they've
gone missing [inaudible].
[ Background noise ]
>> So, is that one of the
things you also want to capture
in the database where there
is a sample that's supposed
to be there isn't in ours,
but is in somebody else's.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: We
don't capture anything
in ours that's missing.
We don't, but as people
add, we will start to see
that would have had one, that
there would have been one
for that month and in some
[inaudible] it's there
and some [inaudible], it's not.
The interesting thing though
is too is that you can't rely
on the fact that in June
of 1864, this is the sample
because it may not be the
sample that's [inaudible].
It could be something different.
Yeah. Right.
>> But, just that there
actually is a sample that exists
as opposed to [inaudible].
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Yeah.
I mean, we're only documenting
things that still exist.
Yeah. Oh. Yeah.
>> The big data [inaudible]
you're taking seems
to be surfacing aspects
of the history
that are purely technical.
The remark you made
about, with albumen paper.
There's this break and then
suddenly there's a monopoly
and as Mark said, you're
looking at the [inaudible],
the cradle of this
new technology.
That's a significant thing and
there might be a, you know,
there might be a
[inaudible] book in there.
What was it that
happened ack then.
So, I find that interesting.
I wonder if you have
any examples of that,
but you also mentioned
that the diamond process.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Yeah.
The diamond varnish.
>> The diamond varnish
resulted in a certain type
of cracking on the item.
Are you finding that those
revelations are informing the
sort of diagnostic
conservation process?
That if this is a new kind of,
[inaudible] way to
look for cracks.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: I think
we will as we get more data in,
we'll be able to say okay,
now we know that this
diamond varnish is a problem
and we have a tin type by
so and so that has cracking.
Let's test the one with
the diamond varnish and see
if we can characterize
that varnish
and now let's test
this tin type.
Do we see the same varnish,
like same finger print
for that material there?
And then maybe we can start
to draw those parallels,
but we're in the infant stage
as of yet, but that's the goal.
That these collections will
reveal all these things
about collections that
we really care about,
things that were really
important and really important
to safeguard over
for a long term.
So.
>> I'd just like to add that
this is a lovely continuum
of a tradition at the
Library of Congress.
When I came into the profession,
prints and photographs had
published a list of books
that contained original
photo prints for the nation
so that university
librarians in particular can go
through their collections before
all the [inaudible] had been cut
out of [inaudible]
books before all
of what's his names studio
book was clipped and destroyed
and it was, it was, it
came from the expertise
of the conservators and curators
in prints and photographs
that informed national
collections
or nation's collections
to get these things
in before they disappeared.
And this is just one more
step in that process of,
as an institution that deals
with the material object,
both curatorially and
in terms of conservation
and preservation, this is really
important work for us to do.
I think.
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: Thank you.
I agree. Yes.
>> Again, a wonderful talk.
Were these processes patented
and would the patent
office have had a collection
or had a collection?
>> ADRENNE LUNDGREN: So,
many of these were patented.
There's actually a great
show and publication
that came out of the Getty.
They just did a show on
the early patent office
and early photographer.
[inaudible], what's
her last name?
Anyways. She, if you're
interested in the patent office,
I mean that show was amazing.
She gave a talk about it.
I was blown away, but they did
have samples for certain things.
Yes, they would have
been sometimes patented.
Sometimes the changes weren't
seen as significant enough
to warrant a patent so they
would have been rejected
for a patent anyways, like they
didn't like to patent things
that were minor changes,
had to involve
like full on, new research.
So, I don't know
if the variation would have
been captured in that realm.
Yeah. All right.
Shall we look at books?
[ Background noise ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov